so I am very excited to be here today I
remember as a grad student attending the
seminar so I was in some of your shoes
and I actually wanted to call out that
there's another fellow some of us
fellows come down to their other fellows
in the audience besides me I'm supposed
to tell you that I'm the lenoir
Annenberg and wallis annenberg fellow at
the casbah center i was told but when
i'm not doing that i'm in a net nyu as
Michael said running this crazy place
called the game Innovation Lab and I was
thinking about the work that was going
on here at Stanford and what might be
interested in accessible to students
here given the current directions and I
thought what I could do is tell you a
little bit about some things that we're
thinking about in my group about
designing social wearables and how play
is related to the design of social
wearables in an interesting manner so
that's the journey we're going to go on
today so how many people here have a
wearable device okay how many people
wear one almost every day so a fair
number of people actually wear this
thing every day but I realized today
that the battery is running low which is
something that I'll get into and my talk
a little bit so it's not actually
tracking my steps right now but in any
case mean wearables are a growing and
exciting segment of consumer electronics
and are also a really interesting
research space for people in our field
and they're clearly a value they're not
going anywhere anytime soon they're very
challenging design space on a lot of
different levels so so one obvious level
is thinking about the tiny screen and
how do you design interesting
information display when something is
small and there's not much you can put
on the screen there's also figuring out
how and when to interrupt people when
they're engaging with the wearable and
they're engaging with their everyday
life and there's figuring out where on
the body you would put something in a
way that's going to be graceful in in
someone's everyday existence so those
are kind of some basic concerns layer it
on to that our issues that arise because
something is sitting there on someone's
body for a long length of time so did
anybody actually have this Fitbit that
gave people rashes and got a rash nobody
nobody in this audience I suppose but
somebody in the back so somebody in this
room actually had this issue okay
this is this is crazy but these are the
kinds of things you have to start to
think about when you're designing a
wearable device that's meant to be on
someone for a long period of time is 0
is any component of this thing actually
going to give someone a rash and then
practical concerns like is the battery
going to wear out and then I've been
working more and more with people in
fashion and one of the things they talk
about with wearables is washability
things getting thrown into the washing
machine and whether they can survive or
not this kind of process so there are
these sort of second-order concerns that
have to do with intimacy to the body and
the length of time something's on you
those are all tough things to deal with
but the kind of challenge that I'm going
to spend some time talking about today
is the challenge of how these devices
intersect our worlds socially so I think
this is a challenge that can be
underestimated and in some sense because
it's so hard to design for these other
issues just figuring out how to get the
form factor right figuring out how to
interface the thing with other devices
figuring out what you're going to
display but it's the kind of thing that
can have a tremendous negative impact on
a product so a classic example is is
google glass and i want to walk you
through that example to give you a sense
of exactly what i mean so so recently
Google decided to discontinue the
explorers program around glass I mean
they're still giving out glass to people
in specific work context but they're
getting rid of this program sort of
putting people out into the world using
using the glass device and initially
when people saw individuals running
around with glass they were sort of like
oh wow that's an exciting new technology
that's really interesting you know it's
great that you have that thing but
shortly thereafter as more and more
people started to have this device on
their face there started to be these
interesting rumblings and resistance
points in the sort of social fabric
around this device so I'll give you some
examples from the new york post from
last july and i'm going to read you a
little a little clip from this article
in april a techie war erupted when East
Village Restaurant feast kicked out
glass user Katie cuz my after she
refused to remove her device kazma i
vented online and hundreds of glass
groupies rallied against feast on Google
accusing the eatery of discriminating
against people who are into new
technology Fifi's co-owner Brian gah is
unapologetic he says feast no glass
policy is for guests peace of mind they
just felt uncomfortable about having
somebody who could potentially videotape
them explains gah if someone were
sitting at a table with their smart
phone constantly pointing in a single
direction and you didn't know what they
were doing with it you'd feel pretty
uncomfortable as well so so basically
people started to be creeped out by the
possibility that somebody was recording
them when they were just sitting and
wearing this device on their head now
obviously Google is an incredibly smart
company and spent a lot of time thinking
about the social context of use of glass
and how it would play out and I actually
I saw a lovely talk that was given by
Hayes raffle and Bob risk camp at Google
i/o in 2014 in which they actually
explaining that their aim was to
foreground the world as the experience
and what raffle says he personally cares
about most is actually creating a sense
of empathy between people so he wasn't
about alienation at all and the kinds of
scenarios that are described in this
talk that they gave our examples like
this one which is you know somebody in a
family group is wearing glass so that a
cousin or a nice can attend a birthday
party for the grandma that they couldn't
otherwise be there for so most of the
examples and the talks they were giving
and sort of teaching developers about
the device were examples in which there
were familiar people interacting with
one another and using glass as a way to
augment what was going on between them
so the use cases were these very
personal and sort of intimate
experiences between people and that's
the kind of stuff that they were
prototyping so so what actually happened
what went wrong this is this is a funny
meme on the internet I I apologize for a
broadcasting profanity but I think it
sort of points to the fear the furor
seems to be about this anxiety about
being recorded you know and it's
interesting because if you go to the
press kit about glass they carefully
explain that you know the default
recording is only 10 seconds and you
completely kill the battery on the
device if you record it for more than 45
minutes
but this is what makes people
uncomfortable and I think a thing about
glass is something that is classic cscw
and I think John tongs in the room but
this notion of reciprocity of gays and
this idea that you know I'm I can't tell
if you're gazing at me there's something
about this this is really too too subtle
for people to pick up but at a deeper
level what happened at a social level
with glass by introducing it through
this explorers program is that people
didn't just use it in their family
context to interact with each other and
use it in the waste that had been
storyboarded and prototyped internally
about how glass might be used what they
did was they did something similar to
what Sergey did when he showed up on the
New York subway and was kind of using it
in context and was like oh my gosh and
like two snapshots of him interacting
with it they went out and started
interacting in public as much as
possible to kind of show off that they
had this cool new technology so there
was an inherent Display of power and
status that was going on and that
coupled with a lack of familiarity on
the part of people who were seeing the
device led them to come to this
conclusion oh this thing is kind of
creepy and formidable and I don't know
what this person is doing and it's sort
of disturbing it created this this power
differential and this lack of
transparency yes mainly about the camera
and I knew that something might be
watching it or is it just the disconnect
between somebody's gaze and attention
just seemed to me anyone who had sat
down for anything period will say that
stoner yeah the last 15 years how the
sense of having a conversation and you
don't know if that person is attending
your work looking up some value and and
and it's really disconcerting so it's
really weird to me that this big company
to throw all this money if this is not
us pay attention to that experience
already notice the camp you think they
can just go tell you how this little
clip on camera they applaud your pocket
when you want to fill I think you want
to
is it really like going to act like
doing on camera versus Maggie kind
you're looking around my disciple well
on just speak to that like something
that I've recently seen in images is
people doing this with glass and
basically wearing it on their head so
that they're signaling really clearly
when they put them on now i'm using it
now i'm in it which is which is if you
think about it a funny secondary
affordance of glasses I mean the funny
thing about glasses it's it's it's
appropriating glasses so it's something
that's easy to wear on the face all day
that you would just leave on your face
all day but you know we have sunglasses
and we have reading glasses write it as
opposed to regular glasses and those
have these specialized functions that we
would put down just as you're saying and
so I mean to answer your question I
think it was both qualities that were
problematic and actually that's a nice
segue into this next slide this is some
really really great work done in England
by Stuart Reeves Institute and Steve
Benford I don't know if people are
familiar with the work they've been
doing but they've spent a lot of time
thinking about spectacle so thinking
about not just I'm interacting with
something or even you and I are
interacting with something but what is
it like for the people who watched who
are watching the interaction with that
something and I think one of the biggest
problems with google glass as a wearable
is its existing in this social context
and people are trying to interpret and
understand the moves that you're making
when you put on glass when you engage
with glass but if you look at this
taxonomy they have you can't really tell
other than from these secondary cues of
attention what somebody's doing and when
very well when they're engaging with
glass so you can't you can't see their
manipulation so well and you can't
actually also see the effects of their
manipulations that well you can't
clearly tell in an intuitive manner when
they're recording and when they're not
when they're attending to you and when
they're not I mean there are subtle cues
and those have been explained and you
know when you interact with you can see
little cues but it's pretty subtle so
what you end up with this is this sort
of secretive interaction from a
spectator point of view and you couple
that was the fact that most people
didn't have the device and hadn't
actually interacted with the device the
inherent nature of having a
wearable like this with subtle signaling
and subtle activities happening for the
person who's engaging it leads to
confusion and a feeling of kind of oh
what is that person doing secretively
with that device whereas if you think of
something like a mobile it's much more
clear when somebody is manipulating the
mobile what's happening when they're
recording why they're recording you can
kind of look over their shoulder and see
what they're doing as well so that's
that's like the question is can you pick
that up before you release the device
okay can you actually prepare for that
and I think this is a major issue in
doing any kind of wearable development
because if something's on someone's body
all the time and they're moving around
in the world using it there will be
social effects you cannot design without
thinking about social effects I think
that the most common tools for preparing
for social effects are storyboarding and
doing internal sort of vision videos and
prototyping and testing things in-house
and storyboarding and videos lead us to
create these sort of best-case youth
scenarios and they're great for for
selling up in an organization the
potential of an idea and where it could
go and also helping a development team
think about what sorts of things they
should build into the device in terms of
features but the thing that they lack
that's really really important is a
resistance a social resistance as if
your existing mostly on storyboarding
and on internal testing and prototyping
and then you're bringing people in
occasionally to play with the things
you've mocked up you can be really
subject to a sort of emperor's new
clothes phenomenon where everybody
you're bringing in is doing the same
kind of thinking about what's happening
and is getting in culture ated into what
the device is supposed to do and you can
miss really important things that would
turn up in a more heterogeneous social
environment yes
social we often react to these social
and positions by creating new social
norms and so may need not have been that
the glasses outcome is just like
rejection I like antibody Oh get this up
it might have been that we as a
community like develop new norms about
how we for example yeah make an honest
signal of the tension right because if I
no longer can because like I'm talking
to James and he's got he's wearing his
wireless rainbows and uh it's contacts
right yeah um there's some other way
that he would compensate to say and now
I'm really paying attention to you yeah
so I guess I worried that it always says
it's gonna be social effects and he's
not gonna see them and they're gonna be
bad hey maybe we need to figure out how
to really understand is it going to be a
game like he's gonna be just done yes
killing it or is this something that we
can overcome no I totally agree with
that and actually the the direction of
my talk is offering a strategy for
innocence developing those antibodies so
instead of having to release something
out I mean I think the major tactic
these days is you know prototype and do
upsell and create a vision and then rush
and get something on to the market and
then see how it does and then people
adapt to it and then your product also
adapts but I think there are strategies
pre-release that can be used that come
out of the world of gaming and game
design that can be very effective so
that's exactly the direction stuck is
going so that's good okay so I want to
do a slight detour before I go into why
resistance matters and do a little old
experiment so I'm so so so I'm curious
which of these lines over here do you
think is closest to the length of this
line and so Michael what do you think
okay but did you guys have even a moment
of like you laughed but did you have any
been a moment of kind of like what why
would he say that how could he say that
why is he saying that yeah so imagine if
it had been James plus five other
Michael and James and and five other
people in the room saying it's actually
it's actually a how would you have felt
and right now that well what happened
was they were okay so yes so so this is
this is famous old research on a
phenomenon called social conformity by
Solomon Asch and what he did was a much
more extreme version of this so he would
have you know say five or six people in
a room everybody what one person would
be a Confederate they would be in on
this thing and they would go through
multiple trials of this okay and after
each trial the people who were the
Confederates wooden would all converge
on the wrong solution together and he
would do it in this way where he would
call out each person what do you think
what do you think what do you think
getting to the person who was the true
participant last so how many times do
you think people would actually change
their answers in that kind of a social
situation anybody have a guess at
percentages says worse nice visit no not
I said that seventy-five percent of the
time people would change at least one of
their answers in response to this and
that's just all to say that we are very
very susceptible to one another's
judgements and opinions in very subtle
subconscious ways and i'm not actually
pointing that out as a bad thing because
i actually think it's a good thing about
human beings it allows us to do things
like adapt and quickly pick up behaviors
to adjust to our environment what it
means for doing prototyping of devices
is that you could really easily end up
with a horrible clever hans kind of
effect in releasing a prototype to a
controlled and contain group of people
who will sort of adjust to your
expectations about what that device
should do and make their own judgments
about it and decide it's cool in a
certain way then when you put it out in
the wild you can be completely confused
by the reception that you get and I
think that's the kind of thing that
happened in the google glass context so
basically my argument is as technology
moves into these more diverse social use
context and it runs into these social
norms and processes that are already
going on we need to actually design a
social experience around the technology
that adapts to and travels well with
what's going on in the world and we
really need to spend some time
understanding the social fabric around
the use of the device and even call
debating and shaping that social fabric
so I think you know based on the work
we've been doing in my lab that we can
use social play as a way to prototype
and test and even shape the social
fabric around wearables so I'm going to
tell you about a couple of projects that
my group is built that have allowed us
to explore ways we can drop a wearable
tech intervention into a social setting
and go for some novel and desirable
social effects and along the way we
learned some really valuable insights
and practices from the indie game
developers that we were working with so
this talk is about the strategy and the
projects both so this photo of is of a
game called yah move which I'll be
talking about but before I dive into
some of the examples I wanted to
actually you know take a moment to
justify why move toward place so what
does play have to do with these other
situations well I think of play as a way
to craft a social situation with lower
stakes it's sort of a place apart and
it's a magic circle if you will this is
a term that who Zynga and saline and
Zimmerman use it's a context in which
people will try on novel identities and
novel interactions in a social group
where they'll let go of and loosen some
of their expectations about how they're
supposed to behave and why and with whom
and step into reconfigurations that you
can provide to them so it's a chance to
actually test out something that if it
were not given to people in the context
of play or a game they would feel
self-conscious or weird or uncomfortable
doing the other thing about play that's
really valuable is there's an inherent
culture around play of questioning and
challenging and resisting and
experimentation so we're used to from
childhood you know taking a game taking
it in ourselves modifying it the way we
want creating house rules and having
having it opinions about how the game
should be played in how we could make it
better so play also provides a really
natural context for trying to keep
people in this situation where they're
willing to give you robust feedback yes
the question over here oh you
just remains there and like pow like you
know you you get it like he saw the
group of conformity and you get like
distortions of perception on that but my
boo think I also talked about like how
like the Magic Circle is not acceptable
because like feeds mutual and has the
school shoppin home adentro like you
know how the Mitchell and my that sort
of like they're just informative hmm
it's just solidified crystallized
version of silhouette hmm could you also
say that players also that I source of
you know like super come from baby like
Mitch your lives yeah I see your point
but I think it depends on the context of
play and the sort of the opt-in nature
of play right when you get into ritual
and society rituals are sort of in some
sense mandatory practices in a society
so those are maybe the two phases of
gaming but yeah I agree with that and it
is a powerful force and that's actually
part of why I use it in my own work in
HCI because in crafting game based
experiences people are much more willing
to do a kind of wacky crazy stay
movement-based interaction that they
wouldn't take on in the same genuine way
when testing it out as as a work based
situation for example so so the ritual
of gaming and the practices of gaming
can allow you to make a different kind
of intervention so so this picture is
actually my daughter at the goodbye
party for us when we came out here for
sabbatical and that's a hula hoop there
and what they decided we had a hulu but
the party and they decided it would be
really fun to all get in the hula hoop
and run around together until they all
fell down which is it which is something
that you wouldn't necessarily think of
if you crafted a hula hoop or for use
right it's a totally unanticipated thing
and but it turns out to be super fun so
that's just to show the culture of
gaming and play being super flexible
okay so first I'm going to share the
story of a game that we made called yeah
move and this game actually migrated
from being a mobile game to being a
wearable style experience and it was
based on an extensive amount of social
playtesting in a wide range of venues
that provided social resistance to our
design
and I want to make a brief note to say
that this game had a little bit of
support from yahoo which is part of how
it migrated into being called yeah move
which is kind of a funny side story so
so with this project we were interested
in the transformative power of movement
on emotional and social connection and
we wanted to build a game that would
purposely bring people into the kind of
think Renee and connection that happens
when you're dancing together and having
a really good time as opposed to when
you're dancing awkwardly and feeling
really bad about how you're dancing and
really hate being there so specifically
we wanted to explore the benefits of
encouraging coordinated movement because
research shows that social benefits and
there's some really cool research about
how coordinated synchronous movement
causes all these interesting things to
happen for people so we're actually
working from a mobile game prototype
that we had seen at this conference that
was built by these guys from Carnegie
Mellon and that one was called move it
and the core of the interaction in that
game and I'll show to you in a minute
was tracking through the accelerometers
synchrony in the motion between the two
devices and the way they had set up the
interaction was they would give that so
each of us would have the app and one of
us would say I want to play the game and
then whoever was around could elect to
play with so it was a two-person game
and then you get a little cue card like
make it rain or disco inferno and then
the two of you had to quickly brainstorm
what movement you were going to do that
would map to that description and then
you get a countdown and you have a
certain amount of time to actually play
the game and then you could get put on
this leaderboard so the first thing we
did we're like okay well we like this
experience but we want to really see
what are the social implications of
doing this is this is this going to fly
as a gaming experience so we took it to
this venue which was called eyebeam
co-op and this this is a public play
testing environment in New York City
that happened once a month between this
arts gallery and this festival that is
called come out and play and anybody who
wants you can bring a game there too to
test it and the people who show up are a
mix of everyday people and expert actual
expert game designers who are testing
their game so you get really great
really great feedback turn the sound a
little lower
so we just captured some of the little
movement cycles that people do
it didn't really matter at this stage if
it was fast or slow movement it was just
were you and think and how well were you
and saying that people were just trying
all kinds of
you
I think this I think these guys actually
end up hugging it out to a one point
anyway so so while you're watching just
a couple of points to make so so what we
took away from the play test was
basically people like doing crazy
motions with each other and they're
funny to watch but the app itself had
some issues one of which was that
because of the nature of the mobile
phone you would fixate on the screen do
a little movement and then fixate back
on the screen so whatever social
momentum you had got with your partner
was kind of diffused right away and the
other thing is that it looks kind of
weird it's kind of dorky to do it it's
kind of bizarre so I mean this was this
is a group of game designers who are
really comfortable moving in weird ways
but from the spectacle point of view
this thing didn't work so well it wasn't
the kind of thing you would do say at a
bus stop with a friend I gather anyway
so um we actually all right I better
ever change the screen you guys anyway
so so shortly after this we're actually
invited to this really interesting made
up to happen at this place called
babycastles and babycastles was this
arts collective around games and
alternative game design practice and
they were doing this event oh my gosh
I'm just full of obscenities today this
event called the screen which was
basically about you know how can we get
away from people staring at screens when
they play games and so the the organizer
said you guys are perfect for this come
and test your game here you're going to
learn a lot from from people who are
playing the game here so one thing we
noticed right away when we got to this
venue was it even though the title this
thing was all anti screen almost all of
the games at the event had big screens
but they weren't using the screen for
everyone to stare at they were using the
screen to heighten certain things about
the game to pull spectators into the mix
and sure enough when we had our game
played in this venue it was really hard
to us to attract players because no one
could really tell what was going on
because I couldn't see what was going on
there was no larger than life projection
about it and they felt a little goofy
and we're doing it so we so we got a
combination of really helpful feedback
and also just deep observational
information from being in this in this
alternate setting so one of the one of
the cofounders of babycastles actually
sat down with us and he said hey I'll
work with you guys on this I have some
ideas for what you could do he said I
think you should wrap this this co-op
movement thing in a larger frame of
competition you know kind of like b-boy
be girl dance battle style stuff so I'm
just going to show you for those of you
have never seen one of those keep the
sound low he was like you know b-boy be
girl dance battles what happens is
there's like a circle there's a crowd
around and then there's dancers in the
center and they take turns and it's very
performative and so what you could do is
you could have you know you could have
the people who are doing the team
interaction now be a team against
another team so it could be you know
like a three round dance battle kind of
thing and we got really excited about
that because like okay all of a sudden
that gives us a really good normative
social frame for this situation it's
like everybody knows about dancing
people understand that people understand
in a sense how to judge dance moves and
can kind of have opinions about what's
going on it doesn't feel weird or
uncomfortable yeah so we embarked on the
process of designing a dance battle game
mmm and this led to an intense series of
changes in in the whole structure of the
interaction and one of the most
interesting things that happened is we
stripped almost all of the interaction
away from the mobile phone and we ended
up actually buying holsters kind of like
the ones you jog with and we we made our
own sweat bands like we got embroidered
sweat bands with the word yeah move on
them I wish I still had some because I
would have brought them here but I'm so
we would we would we would put the
holster over that sweat band and then we
had a two-on-two battle and so now how
do people know how they were doing they
had a very simple you know star score at
the end that they could look at on the
screen and then we also created a big
screen projection that gave a little bit
of detail about how people were doing as
they were playing but that wasn't for
the players that was actually for the
spectators only and we introduced an MC
just like in dance battle so we had an
MC who is actually calling out the
feedback from the screen saying shake it
up a little bit move it
bust a new move etc etc because we
realize why reinvent the wheel the audio
feedback is the absolute best way to let
people know how they're doing when
they're dancing some think did I cover
everything that we changed yeah I mean I
guess the last thing I'll show you some
interactions in a minute is that we
change it to this three round battle
which had the effect of creating this
tension over time as excitement about
performance and you're like one team
would win round one and then maybe the
other team we're going round two so it
created this really familiar
understandable form of interaction
around this this novel movement dynamic
so i'll show you people playing so so
yah move turned out really well it was
actually a finalist at indiecade which
is the big indie game venue for showing
off one's work and it was also shown at
several other exhibitions and this is a
video from indicate and you know I think
what you can really see in this video is
how engaged people got with each other
in coming up with kooky crazy moves and
also that it was engaging for the crowd
an interesting artifact of designing
around movement synchrony was that you
didn't have to copy moves on the screen
for like you would for a game like Dance
Central and sort of copy with the
machine did you and your partner would
would figure out together what was going
to kind of show off your strengths and
make you look the best so had people
with really really different skill
levels competing against each other and
it didn't feel disjointed and they were
actually able to have a reasonable
competition like there's there's one
pair that's actually a little girl and
it's still in her soccer uniform and her
mom who were competing and you know
everybody felt fine to just joint jump
in and enjoy Italy and provide something
and indicated there they're an indicated
set up out in the streets in LA in
culver city so it's just a chaotic
random mix of who wanders through and
who's willing to play and we felt
comfortable going to that venue and we
knew that our game was going to work and
be a success only because we've been
through extensive tuning so after
babycastles we actually went back to
I bean co-op venue and we went to
Parsons monthly game test and we tested
our game every week in our own lab group
and we had a pretty good sense by then
that it was a robust intervention in a
social situation you know that we
weren't just thinking about individuals
and how their devices we're going to
work or I'm going to meet you and we're
going to do this strange interaction it
was the whole context now which was
being considered and so when we dropped
it into new settings we had a lot more
confidence that we're going to pull
something be able to pull something on
ok so that's yeah move the the second
game i want to share is still a work in
progress and in fact we just showed this
did anybody see this at tei on campus ok
like one person yeah couple of people so
um this is a collaboration with my labs
artist-in-residence whose name is kaho
abby and that's actually her right there
and she is pretty much the driver of the
aesthetic choices in this game and she
has a really robust practice she has an
MFA in fashion actually but she spent
the last I don't know five to ten years
building interactive physical social
games that often involve wearable
component and she and I were brought
together by this organization called I
beam which is an Arts and Technology
gallery in New York City and they had an
initiative with funding from the city
the Rockefeller cultural innovation fund
around computational fashion so how do
you bring fashion and computation
together and how do you think about the
intersection there so so this game is
actually aimed at exploring game
wearables and costumes as game
controllers it's called the Hotaru
lightning bug game and that's co-host
name for it and and that is is based on
this this myth of fireflies and I don't
I don't know the backstory there but she
was building upon other mythologies from
Japanese culture and in particular she
was really inspired by this common
writers I know how many people are
familiar with this to each ok ok so so
what Kyle finds so fascinating about
this is this combination of the
superhero costume putting on the
superhero costume and being transformed
with gesture like with the common riders
it's not enough just put the costume on
you have to
drag the right pose and so she was
really interested in well could I change
that into a game mechanic and in
particular could I change that into a
game mechanic that's collaborative
between people so it's not just some
brave warrior on his own it's actually
poses that have to be done between two
people so so this project is all about
not just costumes as game controllers
but also costuming and wearable elements
as a way to transform social
interactions okay so she actually set
out to create her own wearable costuming
elements and she was working from this
story of the lightning bugs basically
her her vision as she describes it is
these tiny lightning bugs battling back
to back and fighting these tremendous
forces and somehow making people feel
that sense of collaboration and
smallness and coordination and
collaboration so these are some initial
sketches she made of one of the wearable
components of the game and then she went
on to build this wearable gauntlet and
backpack it's like 22 costuming elements
so you see the gauntlet is here and then
this is this is the light-up portion of
the backpack and both of them are
actually driven by mobile phones which
is kind of interesting so she she built
space inside for this android mobile
phone and then she's using an io io OGG
board to drive the the lights flashing
and the sounds and the interactive
component of the experience so the game
interaction basically goes like this um
if you were playing with me then each of
us would choose which witch costume and
component we were going to wear and one
of us would be the energy harvester and
the other one be the person who is
actually sending the energy out to fight
the evil forces in the world okay and
both of us would have gloves on our
hands and so so the person who's
gathering energy who's wearing the
backpack definitely these gestures like
this and as they move the lights on
their backpacks slowly go up so they've
reached a maximum energy and when they
get to that point and their partner kind
of has to tell them because they can't
see on their back they join hands with
the partner and then the second person
who's wearing the gauntlet
then waits for the gauntlet to charge up
and they can see this by watching the
lights and then there's a sound to you
know that the energy has been released
from the gauntlet and so you try to go
through this pair interaction which
basically involves hand-holding
sometimes with a stranger as many times
as you can to clear the atmosphere of
clouds so I'll show you a little video
of the gameplay so this is a TI so we so
we recorded everybody we had played the
game we just tossed it all on a tumblr
told people were tossing on a tumblr so
if you guys want to go and see these
interactions you can later but you can
see here here's the guy you know
gathering the energy and then he holds
hands yet to really make contact and
then the gauntlet charges up in them
okay and you can't see it in this frame
but there's there's a sky projected on
the wall and over time the clouds start
to leave the sky so you're basically
releasing energy to disperse these
clouds so you can see well you can see a
lot of things in these videos one thing
you can see is it's it's kind of goofy
and fun it's also a little bit confusing
and one of the things we're really
interested in looking for is how
people's relationships transform as they
go through this experience is it a
bonding experience for them or not and
how does the costuming transform how
they feel about who they are that may or
may not allow them to actually you know
bond over this experience so this game
similar to yah move went through an
extended extended semi public and public
prototyping experience so when we first
when we first got the first rendition
going for eyebeam after the initial
collaboration was finished kaho had
built this huge projection dome and it
was she had sown it herself out of
material that project that like
projection material she'd gotten from
somebody else and and you were meant to
do the interaction inside this this
overarching screen and she had built
this laser into the gauntlet that you
could aim
inside the dome and so you could
actually aim it at targets inside the
dome and should this very complex mirror
working with the projection that tracked
the laser and so forth which was kind of
cool its own way it was quite a
technological achievement but it turned
out that it got people way too focused
on the screen it sort of took her right
back to the same issues we were having
with yaw move which is everybody was
just it was like it was like looking at
a bunch of moths fluttering around a
light bulb right nobody was really
paying attention to the gestural nature
of the interaction they were all paying
attention to what was going on on the
screen and then other little little
things she tried she she initially had
this idea of goggles so she thought the
person with the backpack wouldn't be
able to see their energy collection and
would need help from the aimer for that
and that the person who had the gauntlet
would then need help from the energy
collector to actually aim so she was
obfuscating their vision with these
goggles and totally didn't work really
really bad idea so these iterations all
took place over multiple tests and I
would argue that we couldn't really have
come up with the radical reinventions
that we did internally to our lab group
there would have instead been a focus on
continuing to refine the technological
path we were going down for way too long
but going out into the social settings
like gallery spaces and independent
gaming venues gave us some really honest
feedback and sometimes hard to take
feedback about which portions of the
technological construct we put together
we're working people for people in which
we're not and one thing that's really
great about working with indie game
developers is they will just drop things
that don't work you know and they'll
take a project back to the beginning and
and rethink their core assumptions and
what they're really after is the end
experience for people who are playing so
they're not necessarily like some of us
and I've fallen into this trap myself in
technology research you can kind of get
yourself wedded to a particular
technology or a set of constellation of
technologies and not be willing to drop
some of what's going on in the interest
of the end experience for people so I
present you know if we look back at
lecture let's let's take a step forward
at present she's building more and more
sick
going into the devices themselves so she
got rid of the dome as painful as it was
she I mean she didn't like throw it away
she's going to use it for other things
but she's really focusing on building
signaling through the lighting and
through the sound effects and things
into the costumes themselves to put the
attention of the crowd in the attention
of the players very much more on to one
another and on to the transformative
experience they're going through and
what we've been doing since we started
this a TI we're going to do this at
other festivals over the course of this
year is we've started this tumbler and
we're taking pictures of people before
and after kind of like you know when you
go into a photo booth like before and
after little film strips of play to see
do people's positioning change their
physical relationship to each other
change after they've had the experience
and does the presence of the costumes
change what they think to do when
they're being photographed and we're
doing interviews and and recording
videos of their interaction and trying
to understand what is an intervention
like this do for people how does it
affect their connection to each other so
so how many people think these folks
knew each other they look like they knew
each other they kind of do right did not
know each other at all and and the
photos are funny you can go and look a
lot of times people be smiling and
standing next to each other a little
awkwardly and maybe a little space
between them and after they play they're
doing these crazy poses right because
they've just entrained doing these poses
but they have a choice about what they
do when they're asked to take a snapshot
at the end and what they're choosing to
do sort of validating some of what we're
after so i guess i would say for this
game what happened was a kind of
clarifying and purifying process of back
to the core aesthetic that kaho had in
the beginning that kind of drifted
during the project so she started to to
layer more and more technology onto this
experience in a way that ended up
distracting from it but taking it out
into these social venues and having
people try it out and give us really
honest feedback about it led us to go
back and pare down what affordances what
kinds of feedback and how the
interaction should take place so I think
this is one really interesting thing
about game testing culture in the indie
commune
is that there are these venues in these
forums for getting robust feedback
before you have something fully released
and an interesting side note on that is
that actually ends up helping people
build an audience or following for their
game so you would think well maybe that
would be bad because would lead to
people copying a game but in fact that's
not usually what happens what happens is
it slowly builds understanding and you
know as you were saying that plasticity
and adaptability in a community so
what's happening is a sort of antibody
effect where you test the game you
workshop it with people who are experts
like yourself they give you feedback
they get familiar with it then they go
off and they talk about the school game
they saw on this interesting interaction
and then the next time you're testing it
somewhere there are a few people who are
curious about it who kind of wanted to
see what it was and then they have a say
and then the thing gets modified further
so by the time it actually gets to a
place like indicate or you know some
some other gallery setting there is a
ready-made audience who's interested and
curious about where the thing went and
sort of bought into and entrained with
how it functions so that gets me to
wanting to link this back to designing
social wearables in general so you might
be saying yourself well okay those are
interesting projects but how does that
actually translate outside the reign of
gelman realm of gaming isn't gaming a
sort of specialized context and as I
said at the beginning I would argue that
yes we are setting up explicit gaming
situations here but what we're also
doing is just setting a frame for social
interaction and I think there's a lot
more leeway in designing situations for
wearable use something like glass or
something like the Fitbit where you tell
everybody who's participating in testing
something you're doing this let's say
you're doing this act as if you're doing
this you you provide them with a place
scenario that has some distance from
their everyday life and that has some
objectives to it and has a sense of
playfulness to it I think you can get
the same sorts of results in that kind
of context and I think the reason this
is important is that you need the actual
resistance of seeing people actually
behave in a genuine social manner and
to pick up these complex secondary
effects around these sorts of
technologies so you have to figure out a
way that you can get a group of people
not just the people interacting but
potentially also people who are going to
be spectating something like this to
play acted in such a way that they feel
the genuine feelings that are going to
come up for them when they're using the
thing in a real situation and so I think
the combination of thinking carefully
about social scenarios that maybe don't
ask somebody to be exactly themselves
but put them in a playful context where
they're trying out some social situation
around the wearable combined with
thinking about venues that provide
resistance communities that provide
their own set of critical standards that
you can bring a prototype into and get
some genuine feedback are the two things
that I think are the most relevant about
the work that we've been doing so
thinking about wearables we think it's
interesting that one of the most
successful categories of wearables has
been these Fitness wearables and as we
were talking about at the beginning you
know what what happens is there's
iteration as products are released so
you know the first iteration whoa it
causes a rash we have to change that
right and one thing that's been
interesting to me is so i have this
fitbit flex and it has almost no
interface on it at all it's just these
little little dots and the novel is the
same way the Naboo has just a little
screen on the inside of the wrist and so
there's been this movement as the
devices have come out like typically
before you would see oh maybe something
will get laden with more and more
features as it comes out and you know
people pile on features and that's the
direction to go but in fact what's
happened is more and more subtle
signaling from the device that blends
more and more gracefully into people's
everyday social interaction as those
devices have dropped into these
communities of practice and I think
probably that wearable community got a
boost from being from beginning in this
area of sports aficionados who like to
share share their fitness progress
anyway with one another so there was a
ready-made robust critical community
that these kinds of wearables could drop
into and learn from so I guess that's
another lesson I would say to take from
this if you're working in the snow
main as if you're trying to envision a
use for social wearables that that you
should look for a community of practice
that you can feed off of and drop your
intervention into that will give you
resistance to your own ideas of what it
may or may not be through engaging with
it over time so picking a motivated
community that would actually engage
your prototypes is a way to avoid having
to just test this in the wild by fully
releasing products and I want to close
by showing you a funny video that's an
example of that from the young move
cracked a project so you know since we
were in New York we could actually work
with real b-boys and b-girls and then
this stuff got started way back in the
80s but it's still going on I mean
there's this there's this dance battle
that goes on every year called chicken
and biscuits or something like this in
New York and we and one of the people in
the lab actually knew one of the
organizers of chicken and biscuits so
she brought people from who were going
to compete in that competition in to the
lab to try out the game and they did
some really crazy things so we hadn't
really thought about this but they do a
lot of floor work and that kind of
dancing and so at one point these guys
just started jumping around on the floor
and doing moves and I'm getting really
pretty crazy and so right after this the
next thing they did was they had us get
some duct tape and they try it out
taping the Mobile's to their ankles to
see if they could get better scores from
from the game which they couldn't and
they were like oh the algorithm is all
messed up that really sucks but it was
the kind of thing that you could never
ever i would have never anticipated that
that would happen and it happened and it
happened in the lab instead of happening
out in the wild so that's just an
argument for engaging with communities
to practice and finding resistance from
people and interestingly enough these
guys actually helped us demo yeah move
at the world science festival later so
we ended up having an enduring
relationship with them so they weren't
just play testers they became a part of
the lab community in their own way so so
what I would say to you is if you're
getting into this area too
being playful and also seeking
resistance and that is all i have to say
questions thoughts reactions dance moves
hand through john has a dance move so
really intrigued by your choice of
including a new mini album no because
started building on Michaels questions
it sort of adds to that social Foreman
you'd actually gives you a Confederate
right yeah yeah and so I was wondering
if you could just reflect a little bit
about role that human and that's kind of
think of between that of the lightning
but game where they the actors
themselves have to make sense of its
game about this yeah yeah so that that
moved around during the course of
development so so the education is
actually happening by the program itself
it's it's measuring and it's it's how
fast you move how in sync and do you
make diverse moves but the MC calls out
to the players how they're doing based
on what's going on on the screen so
during the course of development we also
toyed with the idea of having human
judges as well and we tried that
interaction out and what we realized and
this is actually a pretty interesting
truth about how computers intersect with
social reality is that judging is so
socially complex people were really
happy to hand that off to the computer
that the computer could kind of be the
referee and then you could you could rag
on it how unfair it was and kind of have
this fun interaction with the dumb
technology instead of having an awkward
social encounter and judging it causes a
lot of controversy in the dance battle
world like who's judging what are the
criteria and so on and so forth so the
MC actually their role is really more to
create a party atmosphere so the MC in
our case was a real MC who mixed music
in addition to kind of calling out and
like you know saying funny silly things
in addition to giving people feedback
from the screen so that's that's optimal
because the MC is much better than a
computer at sensing when the mood is
lagging or when something bad is going
you see what I mean
so so they're definitely worth some
moves we made in creating an elastic
system that allowed the computer to do
the thing it could do well like sort of
educating the sensing it was doing and
then using humans to sort of amplify the
mood stuff so we did one play test
actually where we didn't have a strong
MC and oh so funny and there was a lot
of guys they're like was kind of a guy
heavy play tests that I'd be in coop
they started doing calisthenic wars they
started doing like antennas jumping to
and they were so exhausted they couldn't
actually finish playing like it was no
fun for them at all really whoa how one
went wrong what the hell you know and we
realized well actually the music is a
frame and the MC kind of bounds the
possibility space for people what they
think is an acceptable move to make
right and then kind of micro adjust the
mood you know like like the MC could say
jokey things about people who are
getting too into it or kind of pump up
people who are nervous you know by
making just the right comments so yeah
that's a great question yeah NEC in
terms of what the comments that he was
actually making to the players on how
how strongly or weakly with a guided by
the actual list on the actual
presentation of the information i'm
kinda game basically how different with
the scenario the penitent writer and
implement text to speech on yeah well i
mean the part where he was so so so the
interface i don't know if you noticed
during the video but there were
basically star a star system for each of
the three variables and then there would
be like text that would say you know mix
it up or pick up the pace or whatever so
so so that stuff was going on on-screen
the issue is when you're dancing you're
trying to copy each other's moves you're
not going to look at it but a
text-to-speech could certainly have said
those sorts of things but in addition he
was also saying things to kind of
reassure and calm people which would
involve a lot of other sensing that we
didn't have built into the game right
like noticing when someone looks like
they're feeling awkward or when
somebody's clearly you know
getting out of step with their partner
and making their partner crazy like all
kinds of little nuance social dynamics
that it would be quite challenging to
track so yeah yes questions yeah I feel
like there's a competing narratives hmm
tation so you talked about the Asch
conformity experiments and how this can
sort of in the case of psychical glass
lead to a bit of a rejection all right
um and yet you also mentioned that
you're socializing people into liking
the game more and expecting it like oh
I've heard there's the interesting thing
and I come to expand any yeah and you
know anyone who like ever owned a pet
rock or play pause and we're sorry I'm
I'm liking what's the 22,000 essence of
this something that's not actually fungi
with sides which one um the I think
there's actually legitimacy there like
hogs okay maybe not the best yeah game
in the world yeah like we're all having
fun because we've decided you're going
to have fun so so so sorry yo yo okay oh
the little close down there is this
there's the positive side where like
social influence is actually getting us
to feel okay dancing mm-hmm it's not
clear to me how we prototype that yeah
because that seems to be the core of
this it's like pop is it going to there
but I think we can like I guess you know
people who create indie games who people
who are part of scenes they are actually
crafting the social fabric at the same
time that they are crafting their
intervention in the social fabric and
they're testing their ideas and how the
social body will respond to it and
that's an integral part of their design
process so I think you can use it for
good or evil I think you you know and
but people are not dumb like you might
have gotten a pet rock and you were
happy with it for you know ten minutes
and then just sort of SAT there and at
some level in your life you kind of
reflect if you're not like the ultimate
consumer on
I'm gonna buy another thing like that
pet rock I wasn't over yet you know but
maybe it was super fun to do the Gangnam
style dance for a while even though it
was ridiculous because so many people
were doing it so it's a fickle thing the
social fabric and it changes over time
and I guess yeah it can be designed I I
think you can well I think you can see
patterns and how people use the social
fabric and you can artfully and
intentionally put them into your design
and you can also release your design
into the world in a way that makes use
of the social fabric I don't think you
can predict I guess I don't think you
can create a major new change in it
intentionally I guess I'm more saying
you can work with it as a material and
shape that along with the context of
what you're doing is feels like it's in
at home unless your context yeah the
feels at home and that is a trial
balloon of the kind of thing you want to
do where you've tested it out and seeing
how people respond so you have a sense
of whether it might go viral I don't
think you can have an idea and no and
certainly that's that's a lovely goal no
no he had absolutely he'd done tons of
songs exactly like that yeah yeah but I
think you ignore that phenomenon at your
peril right like I think you can you can
avoid falling flat on your face like if
you've decided you're doing wearable
tech a you have to realize it is
inherently social because it's on your
body and it's performative whether you
like it or not and it's not enough to
just craft scenarios like small
scenarios and then do a bunch of
internal testing you have to actually
check it out against the social fabric
and that's that's an iterative and back
and forth process I guess is what I'm
trying to say and then the benefit of
that is by the time the thing goes out
in the world it's also much more likely
to be readily adopted because you've
kind of flush out things that you
wouldn't have otherwise caught yeah it's
like a closed beta yeah yeah anybody
else
I when I get this kind of idea of having
fun we applied more generally like not
what fun is the intent of the
application or whatever but if this idea
of making people comfortable makes them
judge things more realistically and you
know interact with them in a way that's
a good test and to develop further yeah
I mean I think the message I would take
from this it doesn't have to necessarily
be play but I think a lot of it has to
do with them how organic and real does
the social situation feel to me and am I
in your territory where you have a
social group I'm trying to drop it into
that's why I brought the conformity
stuff in it's like you may think you
have a relatively robust you know
prototype and you're going to bring in a
group of people to test your thing but
they're coming into your lab and then
they see all these people as they walk
in and even though they have their own
group it feels small and relationship to
this giant infrastructure that they're
walking into they don't feel on their
own turf right so I think a lot of it
too is being thoughtful about the
situations in which you test and trying
to find communities of practice to feel
confident and have their own sort of
dominant group structure so they feel
quite confident giving you feedback
because it's no skin off their nose if
your things still isn't working you know
and the beautiful thing about the indie
game development community is people do
that for one another and so are mutually
vulnerable as they make their things so
you even get expert feedback on top of
the community of practice which is also
super you know and that the whole nother
question is how to cultivate that kind
of community of practice around things
like wearables do you have a question I
am curious about with yo move and you
talked about how in some ways this was
sort of inspired by research showing
that gestural synchronicity creates
emotional synchronicity so have you
thought about where will you test that
now that you have this great graceful
thing yeah yeah yeah well so it's a
whole nother time should have an
experiment that test that in a rigorous
way with the game and I'm actually
Jeremy balancin has some really great
work on synchrony and conversation I
think it's Andrea one is that yeah so
her work really pinpoints that question
so one of the things I've learned in
engaging in building games is my work is
kind of migrated to a more system
building HCI approach of research from a
classical social science comparative
experiment kind of research because
pinning down the variable rigorously
enough to ask the question is almost
impossible with the structure of some of
these things right so another examples
where we've been working with the woman
who does the power posing research about
how power posing makes you feel more
powerful and yeah so we've been going
round and round with her about like
making something that still feels gamy
but it is is confined enough to
withstand social psychological testing
rigor you know and it's it's an
interesting challenge yeah yeah you use
like a computer you can keep a design
for a few years number of years keep a
pretty similar design and if it's
accepted people enjoy it for a while
yeah those are werewolves is it
difficult to work with fashion designers
when fashion is so temporary eating
things may change in a few months time
so if you're designing something
chipping it later this year how do you
know like what are your concerns with
keeping it my current well you know what
so I work with that computational
fashion project and what I learned is
some things change about fashion and
some do not okay zippers do not change
velcro was a big change but like
handbags do not change glasses you know
a certain form fact the the the sort of
human factors part of fashion changes
very slowly so and then the furla fans
on top of that like the materials and
you know the heel goes up or goes down
and that sort of thing like those kinds
of things change change change change
change so I think a lot of the challenge
at the intersection between wearables
and fashion is figuring out you know
it's like the case is on the mobile
phones right like there's a good example
you can just slap a new case on that
phone and then you could have those two
cycles you know happening in parallel
you know so technologies funny because
it actually changes much more than
fashion in terms of the core human
factors and affordance of the sight of
what's going on but that's kind of
expensive in it of itself so nobody
wants to add
another layer to that process so I mean
that's a tremendous challenge in that
world actually I don't have great
answers for that one yeah that's just
throw a simple question but look
wearable technology which you'd like to
see in the world that doesn't exist yet
oh I think I would like to see so
there's kind of a movement these days
around recognizing that quality physical
co-presence and mutual attention is a
benefit but it's pretty tricky to
measure there are people who are
starting to be able to measure it so
sandy Pentland is an example in MIT like
he's got these badges that he uses to
measure if people are talking to each
other and who they're talking to to try
to measure quality of mutually
co-present attention so I think it would
be really cool if people made wearables
that rewarded you for mutually
co-present attention for basically being
socially present with others right
because I think almost all the
technologies going the other direction
like Bing oh my god I have a text and so
we're all like fragmented and not
actually present so I think like finding
and this gets into the thing I was
saying before about adjudication like if
they're subtle signals where you're
rewarded with feedback that's emanating
from you that shows how attentive you
are that could really change things
right it could sort of tip the balance
because we're all rewarded by answering
we get the partial reinforcement by
answer our emails in our tax and that is
more important to us than the quality of
attention we give to the person in front
of us so I would kind of like to gamify
co-present attention in a subtle way
with wearables how's that or like your
t-shirt your t-shirt your teacher gets
colder you get colder and colder the
less attention you're paying to people
and you start to shiver and Lulu and
your t-shirt so i take this blue hue and
you're like okay I kind of gotta focus
you know the kind of beyond Taco Bell a
more visceral more and also observable f
is related but a little bit that's how
it was going to yeah so interestingly I
do have people in my lab who are you
know migrating out of the world of games
per se and
into playful interaction around everyday
experience so things like using gesture
to unlock a door or kinesthetic tools
for fidgeting that can help modulate
your mood so so one of the things I'm
doing now is trying to take some of this
thinking about the subtle social and
emotional signals that are happening in
these play spaces and see if I can move
these into situations where not
necessarily in the leisure context but
you do care about well-being in
connection and how do we actually attend
to those variables and and measure them
as well so you talked about how in the
indie game community there's this cool
culture of people are getting early
feedback you're getting feedback from
communities of people who are likely to
resist yeah and I'm interested in how
this can be extended to products that
aren't necessarily games yes I wanted to
ask if you were the like the lead
product designer physical google glass
yeah what sort of feedback her user
testing your done to ya sure hmmm yeah
it didn't feel that's a question so so
so there's this game company harmonics
you guys all have heard of rock band
right so harmonics did really extensive
internal testing not just in the rock
band group but the whole company and
everybody had to form a band and play
the game and give feedback so they kind
of like use this weird or you're in the
company she got to you know eat the dog
food whatever but they got much more
robust an interesting feedback from they
used the fact that they were of a
certain scale to you know use their
internal community to get some
resistance and some actual interesting
feedback and so I think one thing that
people can do I mean google has a scale
to it and has people sign these
phenomenal confidentiality agreements
right so there's no reason they couldn't
use you know much more robust
heterogeneity within their organization
you know to craft scenarios where people
are really testing this thing and I I
bet they're doing that already more and
more probably partly as a result of like
oh my god why do people think this about
our wonderful tech you know I mean
because it is you know it's very hard to
predict these things I mean you know
it's important it's important to say
that it's important to say nobody's dumb
who goes out and has this happened to
them it's just it's an incredible to
anticipate
social interaction right but that makes
it so high stakes so I think that's one
strategy I think another strategy which
may be less plausible is finding ways
for communities of developers to form
movements and kind of artfully share
things in ways that they are giving each
other more genuine feedback as things go
along and I know that's hard because of
competition but I think it would benefit
everyone i guess that's partly the role
of research you know so in some senses
iteration happens more and more in the
product world we lose that aspect of you
know hard looks of things before they're
actually out there in the world yeah
somebody else all right let's take Kevin
one more time
you